[Music]
he's Davey love use your brave girl
so what's the story young lady
we're on our way to Minneapolis it
wasn't an accident
nice out well sooner or later everybody
does right dad I nearly had you tonight
since you're traveling I'd like to do a
cat scan daddy's gonna take care of I'm
gonna wait right here for you when you
get out in hours you know how much
longer it's gonna be what was her name
again Harry Monroe
I'm not seeing a Perry Monroe there
hasn't been a scan since an idle talk
this morning what are you telling me
they're not here at the whole day in
front of you not finding any Monroe I
just want to see my wife and daughter
happy face don't record in the treatment
areas right that the camera can't see
them because of the chairs you got a
better angle
you saw my little girl you treated her
own well I've got to go in easier that
they were here at all thinks I'm making
them up
why would I have my daughter scarf
another thing this place
she did the picture that could be
anybody
where's concerned about them as you are
start stock well nobody needs to get
hurt
I mean he's a head case
[Music]
[Music]